SIMON-OLIVIER FECTEAU,
réalisateur "Bye-Bye 2022"
- Vous remarquerez qu'il n'y a
pas d'humains, il n'y a pas
d'êtres humains. Il y a juste
nous autres, c'est tout.
Puis si on croise quelqu'un,
c'est soit quelqu'un qui
travaille pour le Bye Bye
ou soit c'est des voleurs!
- C'est dans les studios
de l'ancienne maison de
Radio-Canada qu'a été monté eter
une dernière fois le "Bye Bye
2022", le septième réalisé
par Simon-Olivier Fecteau.
- C'est extrêmement touchant
de travailler dans la vieille
tour en ce moment.
C'est complètement désuet,
mais c'est des beaux studios,
puis ça travaille vraiment bien.
C'est un peu triste, en fait,
qu'on va perdre ça.
Il faisait vraiment froid
parce qu'ils chauffent un peu
moins parce qu'il n'y a
personne. Mais les gens qui sont
là on quand même besoin
de chaleur, même s'ils sont peu.
- Outre la nostalgie des Bye Bye
passés s'est ajouté quelques
défis pour l'équipe
de production.
- Tu ne peux pas boire l'eau.
L'eau n'est plus potable dans
la vieille tour de Radio-Canada.
Moi, je ne prends pas
l'ascenseur. Les escaliers
roulants sont brisés. On marche
plus, c'est l'fun, c'est bon
pour la santé. Je suis sûr que
très bientôt, je vaununununun
chevreuil dans le corridor,
puis je ne serai pas surpris!
- Selon le chroniqueur MC Gilles
qui fait partie de la revue
de fin d'année dn"n"n"n"n"
depuis une vingtaine d'années,
on peut encore rire de tout,
suffit de trouver le bon angle.
MC GILLES, chroniqueur
- Avmpmpmpmpmps, "Infoman" est
devenue pas juste une émission
humoristique, une émission
satirique, mais une émissionpap.
C'est sûr que des sujets dont
tout le monde parle en ce moment
: la guerre en Ukraine qui adébi
que la pandémie s'est presque
arrêtée en 2022, mais faut
quand même en parler.
- En plus du "Bye Bye" et de
la revue d'"Infoman", le public
pourra aussi compter sur
l'émission de France Beaudoin
"En direct du jour de l'An".
♪ ♪ ♪
Et "À l'année prochaine"
enregistrée devant spectateurs
cette fois-ci.
Et les sujets d'actualité,
comme à l'habitude, ne manquent
pas.
PHILIPPE LAGUË, animateur,
auteur, concepteur,
- À l'année prochaine.
- Des choix qui sont toujours
difficiles à faire. Choisir
nos sketchs, ça a été difficile.
Ensuite, choisir les sketchs
qu'on joue ou qu'on joue pas,
c'est difficile et après
l'enregistrement, choisir
les sketchs.
- Nouveau studio ou ancien,
une chose est sûre :
le décompte, lui, se termine
à minuit.
Ici, Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Montréa